so first of all I would start by saying
congrats on not crashing the Ferrari
thank you very much I appreciate that I
it's crazy to realize that this is your
first movie which is it's crazy because
most people start with like a smaller
one that's sure and you're like I'm
gonna jump into something really
complicated and hard and I'm gonna write
and direct it and produce it and just
say screw it yeah I mean I didn't say
screw it but I definitely was like you
know felt after having written and
produced a lot of these movies as you
know ready because you know a lot of
what I've done in the past with these
films and with some other films but
especially these was sort of directorial
because I'd worked with some directors
who were open and collaborative and let
me do you know the kind of work that
maybe some other directors would be more
territorial about so like I worked
closely with the actors on these films
doug liman another director who's a very
open workshop a director I worked very
closely with the actors on the films I
made with him I've been in post on
movies it's so the scale of this kind of
film wasn't intimidating to me because
it's the kind of movies I've been around
15 years I'm always curious if you could
go back in time to day one I'm sure
walking on set that first day there had
to be butterflies yeah sure so what
would you give yourself as advice if you
could go back to that first day that if
you had advice eat a healthier breakfast
honestly the biggest surprise on this
movie as a director the biggest
difference between being what I've been
in the past which is like a creative
partner really two directors and being
the director is it demands a different
kind of stamina that when you're right a
producer on a movie even when you're
really a creative force on it you still
have between setups between shots time
to check your phone to make phone call
to go meditate do whatever you want to
do when you're the director the second
you call cut and people are moving the
cameras around there's ten people
waiting in line to ask you questions so
there is no break from the beginning of
the day to the end of the day and that
kind of stamina is like it demands a
different it demanded a different kind
of diet for me and just a different
approach did you because I've heard that
from other people did you know that
going in or was it sort of like no it
was really when you got on set you're
like oh wait a minute this is different
it wasn't when I got on set it was like
about two weeks in
two weeks into the movie I was like are
we like four or six weeks into the movie
and my body because my body was just
tired sure in a way that I almost never
get tired I mean you know me I work in a
lot of things at the same time and I
enjoy doing that I enjoy bouncing around
the world I enjoy bouncing around
projects this is a movie where I was so
fully immersed in the film in a way that
I've never been singularly immersed in
in a single story and and yet I was
feeling myself tired and so what I did
is I just changed my nutrition this is
boring but I just changed my nutrition
and and instead of eating you know a
bowl of fruit in the morning which was
sugar that was spiking me up and making
me crash I was eating you know protein
and some like that yeah but it's very
interesting that because I've spoken to
a lot of filmmakers and a lot of people
and they say that the marathon is what
surprises that right you know um so
obviously you wrote this and I'm curious
uh when you're sitting down at the
computer you're getting ready to go
who's the character that's easiest for
you to write and who's the one that you
constantly go back to and say oh I did
this enough this didn't come together I
think the you know having written a lot
of these movies obviously and like you
and I'm sure everybody watching this
having read a lot of these comics the
person who has the clearest voice and is
the easiest to write is Xavier for me
even though in this movie I do something
slightly different with him and
obviously make him a little bit more
problematic as a character than we've
have in the past
little maybe a little more complex and
and then we have in the past
he's an easier voice for me to write I
think the hardest voice for me to write
and I think this is he's a hard
character you Scott I think Scott is a
hard character to write because you know
on the one hand he's a sort of innocence
to him and the other hand that there's a
strength that we try in these movies to
give him but he's never really the hero
of these movies and so it's a balancing
act and he's a hard character to write I
there's a sequence in the first 20
minutes so which we can talk about which
is uh when they go to space together all
of them as a group I love the sequence
and I think that it is it's something
that like all of us x-men fans
you know we want to see this all of them
as a team right working together so how
much fun was it to write that thing and
and also talk about filming it when you
have all those actors together yeah I
mean for me the thing the things that I
when I went into this movie I was like
what are the one I just want to tell a
dark phoenix story that focuses on Jean
and I really focus on her as a character
and try to make it as intimate and
personal and emotional as possible do
that properly see the characters around
her the family sort of split apart and
react to it once I've done all of that
and sort of outlined that and thought
that through in my head now what are the
things that we haven't done in the next
movie before that I've always wanted to
do in an x-men movie and maybe number
one that list was see them work as a
team because in the comics and the
cartoons what we love is when they work
as a team and there aren't a lot of
action sequences in previous x-men
movies where they really work as a team
off and they work against each other a
lot of the time they work sort of
individually but them working as a team
excited me and so I sat down very for me
it was the first sequence that I wrote
not just in the movie but like even
before I wrote scenes that preceded it I
wrote it I pre-visit it I wanted it to
feel as though they were this well-oiled
machine of like a superhero team and
that's not something we've seen in the
x1 movies before it was a lot of fun to
direct with them because they were all
in the x-jet together obviously at the
same time except for when a couple of
them go to the to the endeavour to save
the astronauts and it was a hard do you
know it was complicated it was
complicated because it was some zero-g
that we were creating and a lot of
visual effects obviously because they're
out in space and there's explosions and
all that it wasn't all real no no that
tried to make as much practical as
possible in this maybe that was the one
sequence that the studio would not give
me the money to shoot in space right I
definitely want to talk about the design
of Dark Phoenix and how Sofie looks
because talk about how you got to that
point where there are a lot of different
versions of the way she was going to
look sure I mean you I thought a lot
look I looked at a lot at the original
comic and I wanted this movie to be more
grounded and real and I wanted the
expression of what was happening inside
of her and that cosmic force inside of
her to play out obviously visually in
her face and it make it clear for the
audience to to know when she was losing
control and so that the feeling of that
what I wanted to create was the feeling
that the thing inside her that that that
that Phoenix force inside her was
pushing out it's not that she's like
cracking though I liked the metaphor all
sort of like cracking up as a carrot as
a human being as a character but it was
this feeling as if literally her body
couldn't hold the thing that was inside
her anymore and it was starting to crack
as if it was gonna split open which
which you know to some extent happened
but as if she was gonna split open and
that power inside of her was gonna pour
out of her or explode Sofie herself and
so those cracks that are meant to feel
this three-dimensional as possible and
not just like they're sort of you know
prosthetic on her or they're all facial
effect that those cracks are bulging out
and pushing out from inside of her and
we you know well initially I looked at
the notion of those cracks being kind of
the same cosmic colour that I imagined
and was inspired by the comic of for the
cosmic force and it started to look a
little too cartoonish and so I settled
on something that was a little bit more
you know like orange and orange red
Universal sure how tough was it to get
back Fassbender because he's been on
what we call it an extended hiatus yes
um you know I think with Michael one you
know the having made these movies for as
long as I have now in different
capacities writer/producer these lead
actors have become my friends and at the
end of making apocalypse from a new
Brian wasn't going to direct the next
movie the actors came up to me and they
were the ones that said really I should
direct this the next film whatever it
was and Michael was one of them it was
all of them Michael James Nick and and
Jennifer Jennifer actually most of all
and and so you know I think Michael from
the beginning when I said I was going to
direct the movie he said who would
support it and he would come back so it
wasn't that hard to get him back the
thing with all of these actors but in I
would say Michael especially but all of
them is they just want to do something
different they want to be challenged
they want
characters to evolve that I want to play
the same character over and over again
even though it is the same character you
know so I I had this idea also on my
list of things that I wanted to do and
other excellent movies that had never
been able to do is like create Kenosha
so I talked to Michael about that and he
was really excited about being able that
you know live in this
he knew he knows the comics well he
knows that world and so the idea of
building that were all together was
really exciting to him what was the last
thing that you cut out of the movie that
you didn't want to see go and why such a
good question Steve the last thing that
I cut out of the movie that I didn't
want to see go there's a scene that
probably be in the deleted scenes I
think there's a scene between there's a
line from it and the trailer actually
there's a scene but you can catch a
little bit up in the trailer credit
there's a scene between Charles and
Scott in cerebro where it's after Hank
has left the mansion let's leave it at
that
you know the scene and Charles sees it
has a real emotional response to it
starts to head out of cerebro Scott's
there with them Scott's also dealing
with everything that's happening and you
know Jean the person that is the woman
they love is losing control in her mind
and now Charles is kind of traumatized
by losing Hank he's been his right-hand
man for all of these movies and there's
this I wouldn't call it a confrontation
but to sort of break down from Charles
in that scene in the trailer he says I
don't know what to do don't ask me what
to do I don't know to do and I just like
I like the scene a lot but in truth it
was a scene that wasn't necessary in
terms of the storytelling and felt like
it it it sort of you wanted to go from
the next scene to being back with Jean
and I tried really hard in this movie to
not be away from Jane for too long ever
in this film partly because I think I
have sort of maybe PTSD from x-men The
Last Stand where I felt like so much of
the movie is not about Jean I really
wanted this movie to be so squarely
focused on Jean
that there were things that I eliminated
because I wanted to keep that focus on
her I'm always curious and listen fans
of these movies love the deleted scenes
they love what was cut so what can you I
would imagine the blue rains gonna have
stuff on yeah it is obviously for down
the road but sure do you have a lot is
there like five minutes of deleted
scenes as a ten is there now many
minutes there are I think it's like four
or five scenes so that probably adds up
to anywhere between five and ten minutes
the scene that that that I think audio I
it didn't fit the ending of the movie
anymore but there's a great just acting
scene from McAvoy again that that would
have been at the very end of the movie
but it's sort of bumped with with the
time timing of the end of the movie in
terms of where people are so fans will
see that in the deleted scenes again
it's not it's not like a not a big
spectacle scene it's not a big it's just
it's just a drama scene and you you know
you haven't seen the movie know that
it's like a more grounded dramatic sort
of intimate film than we've done in the
x-men franchise before which a large
extent because I really wanted to get
back to a character different place I
felt like with Apocalypse we got really
a little bit more focused on spectacle
and scale and lost some of the character
and there were so many characters in
that movie that like nobody really got
the kind of arcing that you want to give
characters in a movie even in an
ensemble movie so um any rate it's a
little scene that Charles has to
monologue to himself but I loved it and
that was hard to see go to but had to go
because it literally didn't fit in the
film anymore yeah I don't want to
obviously reveal anything for this play
for the people in the room but the how
did you decide the very end of the movie
is a cool scene did you always know that
was the ending or and like sort of how
did you get to it and was were there
other things you were thinking about
with the ending um I always wanted to
end the film with those characters to
give it vague
um because I felt as though you know
from the beginning of and I feel like
you and I have talked about this in the
past for the beginning of this process
and it's just ironic now given the
Disney of it all but from the beginning
of writing this which is three years
I always saw this as the culmination of
this cycle of x-men films know that they
aren't gonna be in more x-men films
obviously they are and whatever in
whatever form they take but I felt like
for the x-men first class storyline of
these strangers coming together becoming
the surrogate family some of the men
amis some of them friends in this movie
the family being as strong as they can
be at the beginning of it and then being
shattered from all of the different
events that happened in this film and
then having to come together in a new
form felt like the culmination of
however many movies it's been to get
here x-men first class days apocalypse
and now this and the Dark Phoenix story
for me and I'm sure for you you know is
that our most beloved story or then the
most sort of enduring of the x-men
storyline so I always saw this as the
sort of culmination and so as a result
because I think foundationally those
characters in the last thing that you're
talking about are at the core theme
Attica Lee of every x-men movie you know
even when Wolverine has been the star
they have been the core of the movie
they're their philosophies are the sort
of bedrock of the franchise so I always
imagined it would it would end with them
I didn't know what form it would take